وفي تل ابيب يحتشد الاف من انصار اليمين
في اسرائيل والمؤيدين لخطوات الائتلاف
الحكومي بزعامه رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو الراميه الى احداث تغييرات على
السلطه القضائيه وردد المتظاهرون شعارات
تقول الشعب يريد اصلاحا قانونيا كما رفعوا
صورا للرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن تحمل
عبارات نابيه وذلك على خلفيه تصريحاته
الاخيره التي قال فيها انه لن يدعو
نتنياهو لزياره البيت الابيض قريبا وقد
حشدت الشرطه الاسرائيليه عددا كبيرا من
عناصرها واغلقت شوارع رئيسيه في المدينه
مخافه وقوع صدمات بين المتظاهرين من كلا
الطرفين
[موسيقى]
اذا هذه الصور تصلنا مباشره من تل ابيب
لانصار حكومه نتنياهو
الداعمين للتعديلات القضائيه
[تصفيق]